[Musique]
la centrale de tchernobyl ravagé par une
catastrophe nucléaire le 26 avril 1986
pourtant des ouvriers ont continué à y
travailler jusqu'au 15 décembre 2000
date de fermeture du site
c'était il ya vingt ans on commence par
l'image du jour
c'est une main sur le bouton du dernier
réacteur de la centrale nucléaire de
tchernobyl le site devienne ville
fantôme animé seulement par de rares
habitants
mais très vite le lieu attire de
nouveaux visiteurs plus curieux les
touristes l'une des premières excursions
c'était en 2002 via une agence de
voyages craignent n il est possible d'y
visiter légalement pripyat une ville
fantôme situé à côté de la centrale
nous voyons les ds je te montreront
seulement ce qui est sûr les familles et
les enfants de moins de 18 ans ils sont
pas autorisés et les groupes qui ne
pourront pas se promener librement
malgré le risque radioactif de plus en
plus de touristes viennent visiter la
ville et les alentours les conditions
d'accès sont strictes après avoir passé
un barrage
les touristes se font contrôler par le
gouvernement ukrainien comme ici en 2010
puis direction des abords de la centrale
pour se prendre en photo avec un temps
limité pas plus de quelques heures
je ne peux pas dire très clairement
pourquoi mais j'ai la chair de poule
en regardant ces constructions
l'intérieur de la centrale est interdit
d'accès à l'époque et même à proximité
la radioactivité est 50 fois supérieur à
la normale alors pour se protéger les
agences de voyages préconise de porter
des manches longues et des chaussettes
fait pas peur cette dose n'est pas très
importante
autre précaution celle de ne pas sortir
des treize itinéraire sécurisé et de
porter un compteur geiger la guide nous
a dit qu'il était obligatoire de le
porter et à la fin de la journée on
verra la quantité de radiations
absorbées
malgré le danger les visites se
multiplient à la fin des années 2010 en
à la suite d'une série télévisée
consacrée à la catastrophe nucléaire
la fréquentation du site explose
résultat certains y voient là une
opportunité lucrative à l'image de ce
guide non officielles qui proposent de
sortir des itinéraires conseillés et de
passer la nuit dans la ville de pripiat
à côté de la centrale
le tout pour 100 euros mais ce tourisme
est interdite sous peine de sanctions
l'amendé l'équivalent de 18 euros ce
n'est pas grand chose en fait on fait
rien de mal
après il y à des sanctions pénales mais
ce n'est appliquée que si on sort des
objets de la zone face à l'afflux de
plus en plus massive de touristes
le gouvernement ukrainien a décidé
d'aller encore plus loin en 2019 il est
désormais possible de se rendre
directement dans la salle de contrôle du
réacteur 4 là où le drame s'est déroulé
il ya des conditions
parmi elles l'obligation de porter une
tenue de protection un casque et un
masque
[Musique]